welcome back to episode number six of
the beginner to master speedrun I have
been getting comments asking why is this
called a speedrun and uh I was just
inspired by Daniel nitzki so uh if you
can call it that I hope I can too I'm
really just trying to show the process
of going from beginner to master and
hopefully provide a lot of lessons along
the way so with all that in mind I'm
coming into today created six
63 uh I think I've played about 18 games
so far so let's hop
into another
one I'm keeping my baby Rosen profile
picture at least for uh a little bit
longer and we'll start with E4 playing
Nagi egoist Triple
7 opponent taking some
time okay we have the first scandy of
the speed run so scandavian defense
defense um it's a more confrontational
opening obviously I do recommend taking
the pawn most people will take back with
the queen and I'll play Knight C3 and
the downside of the scandy is white gets
Tempo pretty early like black is already
spending a couple moves with a queen uh
now Queen D6 is actually one of the the
more topal lines at higher
levels um but the main strategy for
white here is just to develop at a
reasonable Pace I can start with Knight
to F3 I can start with D4 I think most
likely I'll play both of these moves so
I think I'll start with
D4 uh just opening up the
bishop and yeah now Knight to F3 I think
is very
fine wow
E5 so opponent playing very quickly very
aggressively um now there are two
attackers against E5 but there's also
two
Defenders and there's a few options to
consider here I can take the pawn which
will likely lead to a lot of Trades um I
could push I can also leave the tension
and play a move like Bishop to
B5 so guess it's a question like I
should probably consider this first
because it's the most
forcing and imagine First Imagine Queen
takes D1 Knight takes D1 or King takes
D1 and then I'll just be up a pawn so I
think that would be fine if I take and
the Knight takes
back then I'm probably not winning
anything
there like I could take again the queen
would
take but I
am I am developing with Bishop E2 I'll
get ready to
Castle still kind of like that and I
think that's a bit simpler than playing
Bishop B5 which maybe gives black some
other options allows takes or Bishop to
D7 and D5 Knight
[Music]
E7 yeah I think I'll I'll go for
takes I think this is a just move
straightforward and I'll take again cuz
black is is spending a lot time moving
the queen and in that time I'm I'm just
following opening principles getting the
minor pieces
developed and it would be really nice to
Castle and put a rook on E1 especially
with the open E
file and we should keep in mind that
black can't legally Castle Queen side at
least next move as long as I'm
controlling
d8
so yeah I think I'm happy to
Castle
although black can play the move Bishop
D6 threatening mate yeah now yeah have
to be very
careful
um there are a few moves to deal with
this uh there's Pawn G3 there's Pawn F4
Pawn F4 is a little bit weakening
because yeah it exposes this
diagonal so I think I'd rather play Pawn
G3 and the benefit here is I'm setting
up Bishop to
F4 which I could play right
away uh the other option is to play Rook
E1 or even Bishop B5 check uh there are
a few options
here I like Rook e one
though just very simply
aligning with the queen and king and I'm
threatening the discovered pin
in this case the discovered check to win
the queen so black actually played the
opening quite well like I was under
pressure but all it takes is one
tactical oversight to basically get a
losing
position and now it's time to show no
mercy I'm going to take on
H6 and the goal now is just to to
simplify further I could move my
Bishop I think I'd rather Counterattack
I'm going to play the move Queen H5
hitting both Bishops and the pawn and
preparing to get the rook in so life is
very good I was impressed with my
opponent's opening especially for the
rating like played very
aggressively I think um against a normal
player rated 600 maybe white would have
collapsed a bit more
quickly okay so do I want want to move
my
Bishop I'm going to play one more kind
of sneaky move Rook e
one cuz not only is a bishop pinned the
pawn was pinned too opponent gets out of
the
pin so now it's time to save the
bishop Play Bishop
D3 and yeah it's still a matter of
converting end game I mean I'm up a
queen for a
rook uh opponent I was going to say
opponent gives me a free Pawn but uh
actually gives me a free Bishop so happy
to take
that and this is very common sometimes
when a player is down material it can be
a downward spiral where it's just much
easier to keep losing
things and I'm going to
be as greedy as
possible now I have to be careful uh
because even though I have discoveries
if I play a move like Rook takes H6
check then the queen can be taken
so um I think the the proper approach
here is to play Rook
F6 Sheltering my queen unleashing the
check and now it's
Checkmate okay so interesting game to
start the
episode um yeah scandy opening maybe I
misplayed it a little bit I was trying
to follow like basic principles and not
over complicate things but yeah perhaps
in this position D5 or or even Bishop B5
could have
been uh a bit more
attractive and usually I don't do this
in this series but I'm curious myself
what the engine would play cuz there
were just so many interesting options
and I didn't want to take several
minutes think thinking so we'll ask the
engine um oh Knight
B5 yeah Knight B5 D5 there's a lot of
moves that give um give a pleasant
Advantage for
white I guess Pawn takes Pawn is not
among the top five moves but still white
was slightly better okay so let's move
on uh new
game new
opponent playing this person rated just
below
700 opponent taking their sweet sweet
time it is a kind of complex position
here there's a lot of legal moves for
whites but we do see
E4 so I'm happy this this game is not
lasting Zero moves oh and we see Queen
H5 yeah this is a very common opening at
the beginner level because a lot of
players will blunder with G6 allowing
Queen takes Pawn with a fork so against
this the most simple approach is just to
defend the pawn and now I think we're
guaranteed to see Bishop
C4 yeah and again at the beginner
level it is very possible that black
players will blunder Checkmate here um
actually my very first chess tournament
I lost a game exactly like this in four
moves I think I got to this position
played Knight F6 and um it was a painful
experience so the simple approach here
is just to play G6 acknowledge that
white wanted to take we block the queen
and attack the queen and I think we're
going to see Queen F3 so White's still
trying to win
instantly and yeah the best move here is
Knight F6
and not only does this defend against
Checkmate but it's just following
opening
principles and sometimes when your
opponent attacks you early in the
game you you want to both defend but
also do your best to keep developing
control the
center and yeah now okay
Bishop Bishop G5 might be
coming um if I want I could play Bishop
G7 and castle and be very
solid uh I think here I'm a bit more
inclined
to start attacking I think I'm going to
play Knight
D4 a nice activating
move attacking the queen and attacking
the C2
pawn and here really the only good move
for white is to go back to the starting
Square
so basically trying to show that this
this is uh an opening success for black
given that the queen moved here and then
here and now back and in the meantime
I've been
developing U now the downside of having
the Knight here is C3 is probably coming
but I'm okay with that I think I'll I'll
just play Solly Bishop
G7 um normally in King Pawn openings the
bishop
develops more towards the center but
having committed to
G6 it it's a bit more I think harmonious
to
fing and nice thing about fing is um
yeah once I Castle the king will be very
very
safe so C3 uh Knight's attacked I think
there's only two reasonable moves to
consider here is Knight C6 and Knight
E6 I think I'd rather just go back so I
did lose a little bit of time the reason
I don't go for Knight E6 is because I
don't want this bishop being blocked in
the middle game like I'd like to play D6
eventually and then develop either to G4
or to
E6 and White's expanding in the center
uh
D4 now the drawback of this move
is the Pawn on e4 is
hanging now there are cases in different
openings
where a pawn like this could be poisoned
this so I have to ask like if I take the
pawn what's the worst white can do so if
white plays Queen F3 attacking the
Knight and Checkmate I could just go
back also have D5
there so I think this is a a free
Pawn I think it's so common that this uh
this rating level is if you're patient
enough eventually the opponents will
give you free things to take
like you just have to make sure you're
you're spotting the free
material make sure that you're not
falling for any
traps um always have to have a sense of
danger too so yeah either Knight to F6
or
D5 I like D5 here it's very
multi-purpose defends attacks obstructs
the bishop so I'm not getting
mated it is impressive uh I think
there's been three positions this game
White's friend check Maiden one but
every time have to
defend Bishop saves
itself and the knight's
pinned mean the simple move would be to
Castle but this Pawn is attacked by my
Pawn but also there's a battery with a
bishop
so I'm delaying Castle
because white can't really exploit the
king here and it's another Free Pawn if
takes I would take with
bishop and I don't mind having the
double
pawns and yeah time to win another
Pawn always have to be careful when you
put a piece on a square that's not
defended in the Pawn's territory but in
this case yeah the bishop is now going
to be a a very nice weapon for me cuz
looks like I can take on F2 the Knight
supports
it I really thought the bishop was going
to be playing a defensive role on G7 but
now it's one of the main
attackers we see King
F1
and yeah
castling I think a lot of players would
just castle like get the king safe
but I think my king is okay in the
center like white can't really exploit
it and I would rather
accelerate the play against White's King
and I really like this move Bishop
A6 like developing my final my final
minor piece and pinning the Knight on
E2 I think going forward like the plan
will be Queen E7 eventually Castle Maybe
put a rook on E8 and create the battery
on the E
file if there's any new players watching
uh a battery and chess is when you have
two pieces aligned that move in the same
direction that uh it can be a very
powerful mechanism in attacking
pressuring weak
points so I think the most common
batteries are like Queen and Bishop
aligned or queen and Rook or two Rooks
aligned
and yeah White's definitely suffering
here um underdeveloped has lost casting
rights is down two
pawns but the game will go
on
maybe I'm leaving the bishop on F2
because yeah Knight defends it although
this is a very wise move because now
like I don't want to retreat my knight
and then just lose a
bishop and if I move my Bishop
back then white can take take and then
win back the
pawn and actually if I take
here then the queen can take hitting my
Rook so what do I
do
the first step is is to pause and
think I think I I very much
underestimated this
move um yeah I don't think I can get
away with taking takes takes cuz then
this is hit
too
I'm in a little bit of a pickle do I
take on
E2 generally it's not great to take the
PIN to
pce I take on E2 that doesn't really
solve anything like Queen takes
E2 and then I'm
pinned oo okay I have an
idea I have an idea
it's it's kind of high level
but it's actually very
nice I'm simply going to
Castle getting the king safe allowing
white to take and then take and then
take and I do temporarily go down a
piece but there is a move after Queen
takes
F2 which allows me to win back the piece
I
believe and I think we're going to see
this play out so it's important to know
I'm hitting the
queen it's most likely the the queen is
going to take on
F2 and yeah the move here um if you want
to try and find it feel free to pause
the video but the move is Queen to
D1 which is almost Checkmate White's
only legal move is to play Queen
E1 and then I can take on
E2 and the queen can't take back because
it's pinned the king can't take like
Queen
defends so that was a very fancy way of
kind of getting out of trouble but it's
still a question after King
F2 I think I have to trade
Queens like E3 doesn't do much Queen D4
I lose the bishop so I'll trade queens
and we're going into the end game uh
very few games in this speedrun so far
have reached the end
game and this is actually not the
easiest end game to
win because there's obac Bishops I have
double pawns double isolated pawns on
the half open
file um however I have a nice
construction here Connect Four connect
five if you include the
bishop and generally in these positions
you want to recognize your Pawn majority
this case it's four on
two and one of the plans to win
especially in the end game is to make
use of your pass
pawns so pass Pawn is is a pawn that
can't be stopped by an opponent Pawn So
currently my E Pawn is a pass
pawn and I can start advancing Pawn F4
Rook defends
F4 these things defend each
other so the king is actually a bit of a
Target here
I think it's very likely E3 will be
coming another tip all give and this
might seem a little
counterintuitive but whenever it's a
situation where there's obac Bishops so
I have a a light squ Bishop white has a
dark squ
Bishop one common strategy is to put
your pawns on the same color as your
opponent's Bishop
and it might seem counterintuitive
because if I'm putting my pawns on dark
squares then the bishop can attack them
um but more often than not my pawns on
dark squares will act to restrict the
bishop uh now I don't want to play E3
here because that would hang my Bishop
but I'll start with rook
d8 and I think the dream is to get a a
chain like
this uh the dream is also to check
White's King which
is running up the board now threatening
to win the pawn
so have to be a little bit
careful I think it's nice here is simply
to defend the pawn a rook
D6 trying to play in a a a style where
basically everything's defended a
position's super super solid this Pawn
defends a rook defends this Pawn this is
a nice
construction my F4 Pawn is
defended and like already here I can
think about checkmating the king and
like the thought process should
be uh where where can the king move
first of all and there's only one legal
move that King
has so it's a question how do I take
away the square and naturally the idea
of A5 should come
up and after A5 I'm controlling all the
squares around the
king but I'm not attacking the king
until
now and that's a a pretty Checkmate to
end the game um that was a very
interesting
fight I think my opponent was
uh was definitely playing very fine like
to to find this move Knight C3 and
really put the pressure on me and I
think I was very fortunate to find this
idea of casting and the eventual Queen
D1
um but yeah I didn't really see another
like decent option
there so hopefully there's a lot of
lessons to take away from this game um
especially early on cuz if you're new to
chess you should really really know
about this uh Scholars mate opening um
it's something that's played very often
I I think at the the sub especially the
sub 700
level so uh let's move on play another
game I know there's been comments in the
previous episode that people want longer
episodes of the speed run
so we'll have at least one more wow the
same opening
ah okay
so we have Deja Vu G6 not getting
mated and now Knight to
F6 I might play a bit differently like
after
D3 not sure if I want to repeat Knight
D4 although here Knight
D4 I think is even more attractive
because white can immediately play
C3 or at least later
on
yeah play Knight
D4 I think again we're going to see the
queen return to
D1 o Queen D3 okay and this is a move
that was not available previously
because of Pawn had committed there um
the drawback of Queen D3 for white is
that it blocks a pawn which blocks a
bishop so it's going to be hard for
white to achieve like a harmonious setup
Queen's also tied down to defending the
pawn um now it's still a question like
how
to continue as
black I mean naturally like the natural
moves to consider Bishop G7 and Bishop
C5
there is another idea here
which I think I would like to
play but I I'll start by saying like
either of these moves are completely
fine uh the move I'm going to play is
C6 which aims to really put the pressure
on white because I want to play
D5 and I want to create a situation
where I provoke white to
take now White's attack
attacking in a few different
directions but I'm going to
Counterattack play D5 attacking the
bishop it could get messy like if white
takes and it's a big mess in the center
uh however I would take the bishop or
the Knight and then White's going to be
losing a piece
there and yeah so after Pawn takes Pawn
the main point I mean going back to why
I played C6 the whole point was to get
rid of the Pawn on e4 so now I have the
move Bishop to
F5 and now white is having a big problem
because the Queen's attacked there's no
time to take the Knight or the pawn
because I'll take the queen meanwhile if
Queen
E3 I'll take on C2 with the triple
Fork so the queen is almost trapped here
I think the only move that doesn't lose
the queen is Queen
F1 but then I'll still take on
C2 the very least win The Rook Knight E4
I didn't address but with Knight E4 uh
my bishop and Knight both attack E4 so
I'm happy to take and white is basically
in the same
predicament and yeah this is really a
show of No
Mercy uh we see Queen C3 now the normal
move here there's a few normal moves the
normal move of course is Knight takes E2
with the fork even Pawn takes Pawn
recapturing the
center I'm going to play what I think is
actually the best move and it's not a
move
that too many beginners would find but
it's a very nice tactical idea to be
aware of is Bishop to
B4 this is what we call um like a decoy
or a traction I'm trying to decoy the
queen to the square so then I can fork
and win the
queen and with Bishop B4 I'm actually
trapping the queen Queen's attacked and
I'm controlling all the squares it can
move to on the third
rank so yeah it's a nice uh nice
pattern maybe after the game I'll show a
similar opening sequence where we see
Bishop
B4 uh that also comes from the scholars
mate
line but yeah this is a a very
satisfying move to play the oh no my
Bishop now oh no White's
Queen and my opponent's profile picture
kind of summarized the situation they
were in um now I do want to note that
with every game in this speed run my
opponents do get their rating ref funded
um so hopefully it's just lessons for
them to learn and uh yeah going back in
this geme we see another example of how
to punish this Scholars made opening um
at a certain level this can work some
portion of the time but especially for
those looking
to increase their ratings and maybe
surpass 1,000 or 1500 it's not uh not an
opening you should play too often
to expect to win in four
moves um now what I want to show is a
potential variation where after Knight
F6 white has a move Queen to
B3 and the next few moves I think are
very
instructive maybe I've shown this uh in
a previous video at some point um the
idea here for white is it's creating the
battery white wants to take on
F7 and the simple move to play here for
black would be Queen E7 just defending
uh but there's actually a really
nice option that doesn't defend the pawn
uh but rather counterattacks and the
best move here is Knight
D4 and the point is after Bishop takes
F7 we play King E7 and it's white who's
in a big pickle because the Queen's
attacked and tied down to defending the
bishop and if we look there's not too
many ways for white to save both the
queen and the bishop uh the only move to
try and survive or hold on is Queen
C4 uh but then black has a really nice
move if you want to try and pause the
video and and find the way to forcibly
win the bishop feel free to do so uh but
the move is Pawn to
B5 and what this does is it attacks the
queen and now B3 D5 E6 they're all
controlled the queen can't can't move to
a say Square which defends the bishop
and um yeah black is going to win the
bishop or the queen next move um now
there's a funny line here that if let's
say queen C3 we take the bishop and now
let's say Pawn to
D3 there's another tactic in this
position and for those that don't see it
right away um again feel free to pause
the video but the tastical pattern that
we'll see here is very similar to what
just happened in the game that I just
played is move Bishop to
B4 and in this
case it's again winning the queen
because we're pinning but we're also
using the bishop as a decoy after takes
then we get the fork and uh yeah life is
very good for black so hopefully there's
a lot of lessons to take away from uh
from these games definitely when the
opponent brings out their Queen early
there's uh a lot of ways it can go very
wrong for them so I think I'll end the
episode here uh if you have questions or
comments leave them below and I'll see
you guys soon